but now looking back
that was the wrong decision I think he's
gone on to have multiple abusive
relationships since so but um my girls
have had nothing to do with him so it's
true that's kind of yeah yeah my
youngest one did seek him out but
he's not changed so
um she no longer wants a relationship
with him my eldest one remembers too
much
definitely doesn't want anything to do
with him at this stage but I would never
not promote that I think that's
something that they would need to make a
decision for at the time I stopped them
from having that relationship for their
own safety of mine
um I've never stopped it in terms of if
you wanted to do it
properly and down the legal route
um supervised contact absolutely but
he's never wanted to take that so it was
all about control and about me so the
times that he did have contact with the
girls in the early years when I left